Over the past year, as COVID-19 rocketed around the world, conspiracy theories quickly followed. Last spring, dozens of cell phone towers were set aflame across Europe amid conspiracy theories that the 5G towers were spreading COVID-19. In January, a Wisconsin pharmacist was charged with deliberately destroying hundreds of doses of the newly available COVID-19 vaccine because he believed a conspiracy theory that the vaccine would change human DNA. And some people are asserting that the virus itself was engineered by the Chinese. These aren't the only conspiracy theories making inroads right now.
在过去的一年里，随着新冠疫情在全球范围内迅速蔓延，阴谋论也随之而来。去年春天，欧洲各地发生了数十起手机信号塔被纵火的事件，起因是有人散布阴谋论，称5G信号塔正在传播新冠病毒。今年1月，威斯康星州的一名药剂师因蓄意销毁数百剂刚上市的新冠疫苗而被起诉，因为他相信了一个阴谋论，认为疫苗会改变人类DNA。还有一些人声称病毒本身就是中国人制造的。这些并不是目前唯一流行的阴谋论。
A September Pew Research Center survey found that more than half of Americans have heard at least a little about QAnon, the complicated web of pro-Trump conspiracy theories that originated on the message board for Chan. In November, two candidates who voiced support for Q&N theories were elected to Congress. So how do conspiracy theories like these get started and why do they persist? Who is most likely to believe them and why? Is there any way to combat conspiracy theories once they're out there? And what are the consequences for individuals and societies when they spread? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
皮尤研究中心9月份的一项调查发现，超过一半的美国人至少听说过一点“匿名者Q”（QAnon），这是一个起源于4chan论坛、由支持特朗普的阴谋论组成的复杂网络。11月，两名公开支持“匿名者Q”理论的候选人当选为国会议员。那么，像这样的阴谋论是如何产生的？为什么它们会持续存在？谁最容易相信它们？为什么？当阴谋论出现后，有什么办法可以打击它们吗？当它们传播开来时，对个人和社会又有什么后果？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》。
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Karen Douglas, a professor of social psychology at the University of Kent in the UK. Dr. Douglas has spent more than a decade studying conspiracy theories and she joins us to talk about their history, causes, and consequences. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Douglas. Hi, Kim. Thank you very much for your invitation.
该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是英国肯特大学社会心理学教授凯伦·道格拉斯博士。道格拉斯博士研究阴谋论已经超过十年了，她将与我们探讨阴谋论的历史、成因和后果。感谢您参加我们的节目，道格拉斯博士。你好，金。非常感谢你的邀请。
Hi, everybody. So let's start with a definition. That's always a good place to launch. What counts as a conspiracy theory? I gave a few examples in the introduction, but how do you define conspiracy theories in your research? What are their common characteristics? Well, a conspiracy theory can normally be defined as a proposed plot.
大家好。那么，让我们从定义开始。这总是一个很好的切入点。什么才算阴谋论？我在介绍中举了几个例子，但在你的研究中，你是如何定义阴谋论的？它们有什么共同特征？嗯，阴谋论通常可以定义为一种被提出的阴谋。
carried out in secret, usually by a powerful group of people who have some kind of sinister goal, so something to gain from what they're doing. And they usually don't have people's best interests at heart, usually their own interests at heart. Some people think that the belief in conspiracy theories has been on the rise in recent years fueled by social media. But in a paper a few years ago, you concluded that wasn't necessarily true. Instead, you found that conspiracy theories have always thrived during times of crisis and social upheaval, with examples going back as far as the burning of Rome while Nero was away, and that the last decade hasn't been particularly more conspiracy prone than the past. Can you talk about that and how do researchers measure this? Sure. Yes, it is definitely the case that the conspiracy theories have always been with us. It believing in conspiracy theories and being suspicious about the actions of others is in some ways quite an adaptive thing to do. We don't necessarily want to trust everybody and trust everything that's happening around us.
在秘密中进行，通常由一群拥有某种邪恶目标的权势人物实施，也就是说，他们能从自己的行为中获益。他们通常不会把公众的最佳利益放在心上，而通常是把自己的利益放在心上。有些人认为，在社交媒体的推动下，近年来对阴谋论的信仰有所上升。但在几年前的一篇论文中，你得出的结论是，这未必是真的。相反，你发现阴谋论在危机和社会动荡时期总是盛行，例子可以追溯到尼禄离开罗马时发生的罗马大火，而且过去十年并不比过去更容易产生阴谋论。你能谈谈这一点以及研究人员是如何衡量这一点的吗？当然。是的，阴谋论一直伴随着我们，这绝对是事实。相信阴谋论并对他人行为持怀疑态度，在某种程度上是一种相当适应性的行为。我们不一定想信任每一个人，也不一定想信任我们周围发生的一切。
And so they have always been with us and to some extent people are all, I guess you could call everybody a conspiracy theorist if you want to use that term at one point or another. And so, yeah, they've always been there. People have always believed in conspiracy theories. As far back as we can remember, people have been having these conspiracy beliefs and having these suspicions about the actions of hostile collectives of individuals. This is just the way that we are wired up to some degree. And in terms of how we measure the extent to which people believe in conspiracy theories,
所以它们一直伴随着我们，在某种程度上，我想如果你想用这个词的话，每个人在某个时候都可以被称为阴谋论者。所以，是的，它们一直都在那里。人们一直相信阴谋论。从我们记忆所及的最早时候起，人们就一直持有这些阴谋论，并对敌对群体成员的行为抱有怀疑。在某种程度上，这就是我们的思维方式。至于我们如何衡量人们相信阴谋论的程度，
you can do this in a variety of different ways. And as psychologists, as a social psychologist now, we would normally measure belief in conspiracy theories by simply asking people questions about the extent to which they endorse a particular idea, or the extent to which they endorse a particular idea, or the extent to which they should they believe a particular statement is true.
你可以通过多种不同的方式来做到这一点。作为心理学家，作为现在的社会心理学家，我们通常会通过简单地询问人们在多大程度上认同某个观点，或者在多大程度上认同某个观点，或者在多大程度上相信某项陈述是真实的，来衡量对阴谋论的信仰。
And you can measure these sorts of beliefs on specific issues. So for example, if you want to know how much somebody believes in anti-vaccine conspiracy theories, then you can ask people to read a bunch of statements about anti-vaccine conspiracy theories. So for example, that pharmaceutical companies are hiding information about vaccine, efficacy, and safety. And then you ask them how much they believe that statement,
你可以衡量对特定问题的这类信仰。例如，如果你想知道某人对反疫苗阴谋论的相信程度，那么你可以让人们阅读一系列关于反疫苗阴谋论的陈述。例如，制药公司隐瞒了关于疫苗效力和安全性的信息。然后你问他们有多相信这个陈述，
know how much they agree with it, how much they think it's plausible. There are various different ways that you can do this. And another way to kind of tap into what some would argue is an underlying tendency to just believe conspiracy theories more generally. You can ask more general questions or ask people to rate the extent to which they believe in statements such as governments often hide secrets from people to suit their own ends. general notions of conspiracy like that. So we'll just ask participants to read these sort of statements and rate the extent to which they agree with them, usually on a
知道他们有多同意它，他们认为它有多合理。你可以通过各种不同的方式来做到这一点。另一种挖掘某些人所说的更普遍的相信阴谋论的潜在倾向的方法是，你可以问一些更笼统的问题，或者让人们评价他们在多大程度上相信诸如“政府经常为了自己的目的而向人们隐瞒秘密”之类的陈述。像这样的一般性阴谋概念。所以我们只是让参与者阅读这些陈述，并评价他们在多大程度上同意它们，通常是在一个
scale from I strongly disagree to I strongly agree that kind of thing. And then usually what we will do is come up with an average conspiracy belief measure or score I suppose total for each individual and then we'll look for associations between that kind of belief and various other psychological factors as well. So the belief is generally always out there. The conspiracies may change over time, but I'm wondering have there been times in history that you've seen when conspiracy theories have spiked? Not necessarily. It's not something I really research in my own studies, but naturally a lot of people are very concerned at the moment that we're seeing
从“我非常不同意”到“我非常同意”的量表上，诸如此类。然后我们通常会得出一个平均的阴谋信仰衡量标准或分数，我想是每个人的总分，然后我们也会寻找这种信仰与各种其他心理因素之间的联系。所以这种信仰通常一直存在。阴谋可能会随时间而改变，但我很好奇，在历史上你是否见过阴谋论激增的时期？不一定。这不是我在自己的研究中真正研究的内容，但自然地，很多人目前非常担心我们正在看到
a bit of a spike in believing conspiracy theories with the whole coronavirus situation and also in the USA with the recent presidential election. And I guess time will tell if we if conspiracy theories have I guess been on the rise in this particular point in time compared to times in the past or times in the future. But there is definitely quite a lot of concern that conspiracy theories are on the rise. It's difficult for me to say whether or not they are because I don't really have the data to support, you know, one way or another. But I think that it is definitely the case that even if we can't say for sure that social media has increased conspiracy theories, it certainly changed the way in which people access this information, the ways in which they share this information. And also,
随着整个冠状病毒局势以及美国最近的总统选举，相信阴谋论的人数有所激增。我想时间会证明，与过去或未来的时期相比，阴谋论在此时此刻是否真的有所上升。但确实有很多人担心阴谋论正在抬头。我很难说它们是否真的在上升，因为我没有数据来支持这一点，无论是哪种方式。但我认为，即使我们不能肯定地说社交媒体增加了阴谋论，它肯定改变了人们获取这些信息的方式，以及他们分享这些信息的方式。而且，
I feel that in many cases, for people who do have have, I guess, an underlying tendency to believe in a particular conspiracy theory or conspiracy theories in general, it's much easier for people to find this sort of information now than it ever has been before. And people can become consumed by this information. They can only seek out this information online so they can go to particular sources, disregard other sources that kind of contradict their views so that they end up, if anything, their attitudes about this particular alleged conspiracy theories, or alleged conspiracies rather, sorry, can become even more polarized. So people's attitudes might become stronger. So I guess what I'm trying to say is that even if we don't
我觉得在很多情况下，对于那些确实有某种潜在倾向去相信特定阴谋论或一般阴谋论的人来说，现在比以往任何时候都更容易找到这类信息。人们可能会被这些信息所吞噬。他们只能在网上寻找这些信息，所以他们可以去特定的来源，无视其他与他们观点相矛盾的来源，以至于如果说有什么不同的话，他们对这些所谓的阴谋论，或者更确切地说是所谓的阴谋的看法，可能会变得更加两极分化。所以人们的态度可能会变得更强烈。所以我想说的是，即使我们没有
have evidence that conspiracy theorizing has increased, I think that, and time will tell whether or not that's true. I do think that people's attitudes have become stronger as a result of interacting and sharing and consuming this information on social media and on the internet generally. I'm just wondering, I think I read that there may have been a measurable increase in conspiracy theory theorizing around the turn of the 20th century because of the Industrial Revolution and then also around the end of the Second World War and the beginning of the Cold War. So is that accurate? I think I have come across one study which suggests that that's the case.
证据表明阴谋论有所增加，我认为，时间会证明这是否属实。我确实认为，由于在社交媒体和互联网上互动、分享和消费这些信息，人们的态度已经变得更加强烈。我只是在想，我好像读到过，在20世纪之交，由于工业革命，以及第二次世界大战结束和冷战开始时，阴谋论可能出现了可衡量的增长。那么这是准确的吗？我想我确实看到过一项研究，表明情况确实如此。
But yeah, the evidence is really quite limited and only drawn from a particular type of sources like letters to newspapers and that sort of thing. So it's really difficult to tell, but it does make sense. sense to me that there would have been particular periods in history that conspiracy theories would have been more prominent. And personally, I think we might be in one of those periods right now. Let's talk a little bit about the psychological factors that motivate people to believe in conspiracy theories. I know you've laid out in your research three areas that you call epistemic, existential, and social motives. Can you explain what they are, what those terms mean? Yes, of course. We argue
但证据确实非常有限，而且仅来自特定类型的来源，如给报纸的信件之类。所以真的很难说，但对我来说，历史上确实存在某些时期阴谋论会更加突出，这是有道理的。我个人认为，我们现在可能正处于其中一个时期。让我们谈谈激励人们相信阴谋论的心理因素。我知道你在研究中提出了三个领域，你称之为认知动机、存在动机和社会动机。你能解释一下它们是什么，这些术语意味着什么吗？是的，当然。我们认为
that people are drawn to conspiracy theories in order to satisfy or in an attempt to satisfy three important psychological motives. And the first of these motives are epistemic motives. And I guess in a nutshell, epistemic motives really just refer to the need for knowledge and certainty and I guess the motive or desire to have information. And when something major happens, When a big event happens, people naturally want to know why that happened. They want an explanation and they want to know the truth, but they also want to feel certain of that truth. And some psychological evidence suggests that people are drawn to conspiracy theories when they do feel uncertain, either in specific situations or more generally.
人们被阴谋论所吸引，是为了满足或试图满足三个重要的心理动机。这些动机中的第一个是认知动机。我想简而言之，认知动机实际上只是指对知识和确定性的需求，以及我想对信息的动机或渴望。当重大事件发生时，当一件大事发生时，人们自然想知道为什么会发生。他们想要一个解释，他们想知道真相，但他们也想对那个真相感到确定。一些心理学证据表明，当人们感到不确定时，无论是在特定情况下还是在更普遍的情况下，他们都会被阴谋论所吸引。
And there are other epistemic reasons why people believe in conspiracy theories as well, in relation to this sort of need for knowledge and certainty. So people with lower levels of education tend to be drawn to conspiracy theories. And we don't argue that's because people are not intelligent. It's simply that they haven't been allowed to have or haven't been given access to the tools to allow them to differentiate between good sources
还有其他认知原因导致人们相信阴谋论，这与这种对知识和确定性的需求有关。所以受教育程度较低的人往往会被阴谋论所吸引。我们并不是说这是因为人们不聪明。只是他们没有被允许拥有或没有获得工具来让他们区分好的来源
and bad sources or credible sources and non-credible sources. So they're looking for that knowledge and certainty but not necessarily looking in the right places. And the second set of motives, we would call existential motives. And really they just refer to people's needs to be or to feel safe and secure in the world that they live in. And also to feel that they have some kind of power or autonomy over the things that happen to them as well. So again, when something happens, people don't like to feel powerless. They don't like to feel out of control.
和坏的来源，或者可信的来源和不可信的来源。所以他们是在寻找那种知识和确定性，但不一定是在正确的地方寻找。第二组动机，我们称之为存在动机。它们实际上只是指人们在他们所生活的世界中感到安全和可靠的需求。以及感到他们对发生在他们身上的事情拥有某种权力或自主权。所以同样，当事情发生时，人们不喜欢感到无能为力。他们不喜欢感到失去控制。
And so reaching to conspiracy theories might, I guess, at least allow people to feel that they have information that at least explains why they don't have any control over this situation. And research has shown that people who do feel powerless and disillusioned do tend to gravitate more towards conspiracy theories. and the final set of motives we would call social motives and those refer to people's desire to feel good about themselves as individuals and also feel good about themselves in terms of the groups that they belong to. And I guess at the individual level, people like to feel, well, they like to have high self-esteem, they like to feel good about themselves. and potentially one way of doing that is to feel that you have access to information that other people don't necessarily have. And this is quite a common rhetorical tool that people use when they talk about conspiracy theories, that everybody else is some kind of sheep, but that they know the truth. They have the truth.
所以接触阴谋论可能，我想，至少能让人们感到他们拥有至少能解释为什么他们对这种情况没有任何控制权的信息。研究表明，那些确实感到无能为力和幻灭的人确实倾向于更多地倾向于阴谋论。最后一组动机我们称之为社会动机，它们指的是人们作为个体对自己感觉良好的愿望，以及在他们所属的群体方面对自己感觉良好的愿望。我想在个人层面上，人们喜欢感觉，嗯，他们喜欢拥有高自尊，他们喜欢对自己感觉良好。
And having that kind of belief, I guess feeling that you're in possession of information that other people don't have can give you a feeling of superiority over others. And we have found and others have shown as well that a need for uniqueness and a need to have, I guess, stand out from others is associated with belief in conspiracy theories. And this happens at the level of the group as well. So people who have an overinflated sense of the importance
而做到这一点的一种潜在方法是，感觉你拥有其他人不一定拥有的信息。这是人们在谈论阴谋论时使用的一种相当常见的修辞工具，即其他人都是某种绵羊，但他们知道真相。他们掌握了真相。
of the groups that they belong to, but at the same time, the feeling that those groups are underappreciated, those kinds of feelings as well draw people towards conspiracy theories, especially conspiracy theories about their groups. So in having those sorts of beliefs, you can maintain the idea that your group is good and moral and upstanding, whereas others are the evil doers out there who are trying to ruin it for everybody else. So those three main motives, those three psychological motives, the epistemic existential and social, is possible to summarize, I guess, the psychological literature on conspiracy theories into those three motivations. So, yeah, that's what we argue.
拥有那种信仰，我想感觉你掌握了其他人没有的信息，可以给你一种优于他人的感觉。我们已经发现，其他人也表明，对独特性的需求和对拥有，我想，从他人中脱颖而出的需求，与对阴谋论的信仰有关。这种情况也发生在群体层面。所以那些对他们所属群体的重要性有过度膨胀感的人
What role, if any, does narcissism play in belief in conspiracy theories? And people who tend to be more narcissistic also believe in these theories as a means of getting that sort of the social capital? Yes, absolutely. That is true. And that's kind of what I was referring to. It's linked to the idea of need for uniqueness as well. That's another, I guess, narcissistic notion that you have, you're in possession of information that other people don't have your different to other people and it makes you stand apart. But yes, narcissism at an individual level has been associated in quite a few studies now with belief in conspiracy theories. And also this narcissism at the group level as well. So an over-involveillance. inflated sense of the importance of your own group, that kind of insecure feeling about your own group is also associated with belief in conspiracy theories. So yes, narcissism is one of those individual differences, variables that does correlate with belief in conspiracy theories.
但同时，感觉这些群体被低估了，这些感觉也会把人们引向阴谋论，特别是关于他们群体的阴谋论。所以拥有这些信仰，你可以维持这样一种观念，即你的群体是善良、道德和正直的，而其他人则是试图为其他人破坏这一切的恶人。所以这三个主要动机，这三个心理动机，认知、存在和社会，我想把关于阴谋论的心理学文献总结为这三个动机是可能的。所以，是的，这就是我们的论点。
So a few moments ago you talked about education level as being a factor. And I'm wondering, what about other demographic categories such as age or gender? Do you see any associations between those and tendency to believe in conspiracy theories? Yes. In terms of age, we do. In our research, we generally find that older people believe in conspiracy theories less than younger people do. That tends to show up in most of the studies that we have run. So there's simply a correlation between conspiracy belief and age that is a negative of correlations. So the more you, the older you are, the less you believe in conspiracy theories or the other way around, the younger you are, the more you believe in conspiracy theories. And that
自恋在相信阴谋论中起什么作用（如果有的话）？那些倾向于更自恋的人是否也相信这些理论，作为获得那种社会资本的一种手段？是的，绝对是。这是真的。这正是我想提到的。它也与对独特性的需求这一概念有关。这是另一个，我想，自恋的概念，即你拥有，你掌握了其他人没有的信息，你与其他人不同，这让你与众不同。但是的，个人层面的自恋在相当多的研究中现在已经与对阴谋论的信仰联系在一起。群体层面的这种自恋也是如此。所以一种过度膨胀的对自己群体重要性的感觉，那种对自己群体的不安全感，也与对阴谋论的信仰有关。所以是的，自恋是那些确实与对阴谋论的信仰相关的个体差异变量之一。
does tend to show up pretty much all of the time. In terms of gender, we, at least in the research that myself and my colleagues have conducted, we've never found any differences in terms of, gender differences in terms of conspiracy belief. So as we measure belief in conspiracy theories using these psychological scales, we have never found that men believe more than women or women believe more than men or whatever. We've never, we've never found anything like that. I think one or two studies may have shown gender differences for specific conspiracy theories. Like I know of a recent study that, and I can't remember which direction it went in actually, but that showed that in terms of COVID-19 conspiracy theories,
所以几分钟前你谈到了受教育程度是一个因素。我想知道，其他人口统计类别，如年龄或性别呢？你是否看到这些与相信阴谋论的倾向之间有任何联系？是的。在年龄方面，我们确实看到了。在我们的研究中，我们通常发现老年人比年轻人更少相信阴谋论。这在我们进行的大多数研究中往往都会显示出来。所以阴谋信仰和年龄之间确实存在相关性，这是一种负相关。所以你越，你年龄越大，你相信阴谋论的程度就越低，或者反过来，你越年轻，你相信阴谋论的程度就越高。而这
there was some kind of gender difference. But personally, I've never found that, which I think is very interesting and kind of counterintuitive in a way, because if people think about the prototypical conspiracy theorist, again, if you want to use that term to describe people, then they do tend to think of a middle-aged, white, man, usually. And that may be the case for the prominent conspiracy theorists, you know, your well-known people who propagate these conspiracy theories, but not necessarily your everyday person who's
确实往往几乎总是显示出来。在性别方面，我们，至少在我本人和我的同事所进行的研究中，我们从未发现性别在阴谋信仰方面有任何差异。所以当我们使用这些心理量表来衡量对阴谋论的信仰时，我们从未发现男性比女性相信得多，或者女性比男性相信得多，或者其他什么。我们从未，我们从未发现过类似的情况。我想有一两项研究可能显示了特定阴谋论的性别差异。比如我知道最近的一项研究，我其实不记得它是哪个方向了，但它显示在新冠病毒阴谋论方面，
consuming this information on the internet and deciding whether or not it's true. We don't really find those gender differences there. That's really interesting. I mean, because it is when you see, we just had this overrun of the US capital here in Washington, and it looked like there were a lot of younger and middle-aged men out there. I mean, certainly there were women involved, but that was the sense. And of course, that is the conspiracy theory that the Trump election was stolen. Yes, yeah, that's true. I think, yeah, that's extremely interesting. And of course, I was watching this on the news as well and thinking very much the same thing. But I think that there probably is a difference in the person who sits at home and reads this information on the internet and decides whether or not it's true,
确实存在某种性别差异。但我个人从未发现这一点，我认为这非常有趣，而且在某种程度上有点违反直觉，因为如果人们想到典型的阴谋论者，同样，如果你想用这个词来描述人们，那么他们确实倾向于想到一个中年、白人、男性，通常是这样。这对于杰出的阴谋论者，你知道，那些传播这些阴谋论的知名人士来说可能是这样，但不一定是你每天在互联网上消费这些信息并决定它是否真实的人。我们并没有真正发现那里的性别差异。这真的很有趣。我的意思是，因为当你看到，我们刚刚在华盛顿发生了这次美国国会大厦的冲击事件，看起来外面有很多年轻和中年的男性。我的意思是，当然有女性参与，但那是那种感觉。当然，这就是特朗普选举被窃取的阴谋论。是的，是的，那是真的。我想，是的，这非常有趣。当然，我也在新闻上看到了这一点，并且有同样的想法。但我认为，坐在家里在互联网上阅读这些信息并决定它是否真实的人，与那些准备好真正去冲击一座建筑物或出去并基于这些阴谋信仰积极制造麻烦的个人之间，可能确实存在差异。所以那里可能发生了很多事情，但就我们衡量对阴谋论的信仰的方式而言，我们只是没有，这些可能看起来很明显的性别差异，在我们在普通人群中所做的研究中似乎并没有表现出来，我想。你的另一项研究发现，相信一个阴谋论的人更有可能相信其他阴谋论，即使这些理论直接相互矛盾。所以，例如，你的参与者越相信戴安娜王妃伪造了自己的死亡，他们也就越相信她是被谋杀的。
and the individuals who are prepared to actually go and storm a building or to go out and actively cause trouble based on these conspiracy beliefs. So there's probably a lot going on there, but in terms of the way we kind of measure belief in conspiracy theories, we just don't, with these sorts of gender differences that might see, seem obvious don't seem to play out really in the research that we do on the everyday population, I suppose. Another of your studies found that people who believe in one conspiracy theory are more likely to believe in others, even when those theories directly contradict each other. So, for instance, the more your participants believe that Princess Diana faked her own death, the more they also believe that she was murdered.
当然，这根本说不通。你能帮忙解释一下吗？解释一下吗？是的，当然。是的，我们觉得这是一个，这是一个，这是一个非常有趣的发现，显然。我们有点，我想从文献中经常发现的一点开始，即如果人们相信一个阴谋论，那么他们很可能也会相信其他阴谋论。所以换句话说，有什么东西把这些信仰联系在一起。所以我们有兴趣找出，嗯，这种潜在的信仰体系或潜在的态度是什么，这可能意味着这些阴谋信仰在同一时间被持有，即使它们确实相互矛盾
And of course, that doesn't make any sense. Can you help explain that? explain that? Yeah, of course. Yes, we feel that that's a, that's, that is a very interesting finding, obviously. We kind of, I guess started from the point that in the literature, it's often being found that if people believe in one conspiracy theory, then they're likely to believe in others. So in other words, there's something that kind of holds these beliefs together. So we were interested to find out, well, what is this underlying belief system or underlying attitude that might mean that these conspiracy beliefs are held at the same time, even if they do contradict
彼此。所以我们着手进行这些研究。所以我们让这些研究中的参与者评价他们在多大程度上同意不同的阴谋论。例如，一个戴安娜王妃被王室暗杀，另一个她被军情五处暗杀，与王室无关，或者其他人也一样，但关键的是，我想，一个她被暗杀并且已经死亡，另一个她被帮助伪造了自己的死亡，并且她正在某个岛上过着美好的生活。所以她要么，基本上，不可能同时既死又活。不像薛定谔的猫。
one another. So we set to do these studies. And so we asked participants in this studies to rate the extent to which they agree with different conspiracy theories. One, for example, that Princess Diana was was assassinated by the Royal Family, another one that she was assassinated by MI5, nothing to do with the Royal Family, or others also, but crucially, I think, one that she was assassinated and is dead, and another that she was helped to fake her own death and that she's sort of living it up somewhere on an island having a great time. So she's either, basically, it's not possible to be dead and alive at the same time. Unlike Schrodinger's cat.
是的，嗯，就是这样。是的。我们认为，我们认为人们不会同时持有这两个阴谋论。但事实证明他们确实持有。或者至少他们准备好接受这两件事都可能是真的想法。但我们也衡量了人们相信的程度，我想一个潜在的阴谋论，即某件事就是不对劲。
Yeah, well, that's, that's it. Yes. We thought, it's just, we thought people would not entertain these two conspiracy theories at the same time. But it turned out that they did. Or at least they were prepared to entertain the idea that both of those things might be true. But we also measured the extent to which people believed, in I guess an underlying conspiracy theory that something just isn't right.
某事发生了，某事正在被掩盖。我们发现的是，有些人确实支持这些相互矛盾的阴谋论，或者至少，他们很可能同时持有这两个想法。但一旦我们也考虑了他们相信某事就是不对劲的程度，
Something's up and something is being covered up. And what we found was that some people did indeed endorse these contradictory conspiracy theories or again at least be, were likely to entertain those two ideas at the same time. But once we also took into account the extent to which they believed that there was just something up,
那么这种关系实际上就消失了。所以相互矛盾的信仰之间的关系被我所说的潜在的信仰所解释，即某事正在被掩盖。所以你可以解释为什么人们会持有这些相互矛盾的想法，因为这两个想法都与潜在的观念一致，即某事就是不太对劲。所以这并不一定意味着他们会绝对相信戴安娜王妃已经死了，同时又相信她还活着。但他们会乐于接受这两个
then that relationship actually disappeared. So it was the relationship between the contradictory beliefs was explained by the I guess underlying belief that just something is being covered up. So you can explain why people will entertain these contradictory ideas because both of those ideas are consistent with the underlying idea that there's just something not quite right. So it's not necessarily to say that they will definitely believe that Princess Diana is dead and at the same time believe that she's still alive. But they'll be happy to entertain the idea that those two
事情是可能的想法，只要他们也持有这样一种信仰，即这些事件中确实有某些事情不太对劲。是的。是的。这至少有一点帮助解释它。那么，是什么让一个阴谋论流行起来并具有持久力呢？是否有某些类型的理论比其他理论更具粘性，或者有些理论更不具粘性？比如地球是平的，从古至今一直存在。那么是否有特征使它们更具粘性？这不是我本人做过研究的内容，老实说，但我认为这是一个引人入胜的问题。
things are possible as long as they also entertain the belief that there was just something that wasn't right about those events. Yeah. Yeah. That helps explain it at least a little bit. Well, what makes a conspiracy theory catch on and have staying power? Are there certain types of theories that are stickier than others or some that are more indefiaries? during like the earth is flat, has been around since forever. So are there characteristics that make them stickier? That's not something that I've done research on myself, to be honest, but I think it's a fascinating question.
确实有一些阴谋论经受住了时间的考验，而另一些则消失了。我认为阴谋论一定有某些特征，那些持续存在的和那些没有持续存在的，我个人不知道，它们到底是什么。但我猜有一件事往往非常、非常普遍，那就是事件非常、非常大。由阴谋论解释的事件非常、非常大且重要，通常涉及具有重大政治或社会意义的事情。你可能遇到的许多其他阴谋论只是消失了。我想很多时候我们真的不知道为什么它们没有。它们没有。它们没有。流行起来。但很多，很多确实流行起来了。是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题。这是你追求的一条研究路线。是的，是的。哦，是的。绝对有。是的。
It's very true that some conspiracy theories stand the test of time and others just disappear. I think that there must be certain features of conspiracy theories, the ones that last and the ones that don't, I don't personally know, exactly what they are. But I guess one thing that tends to be very, very common is that the event is very, very large. The event that is explained by the conspiracy theory is very, very large and important and usually involving something of great political or social significance. A lot of other conspiracy theories that you might come across just sort of disappear. I guess a lot of the time we just don't really know why they don't. They don't. They don't. don't catch on. But plenty of them, plenty of them do. Yeah, it's a really interesting question. It's a line of research for you to pursue. Yeah, yeah. Oh, yeah. There definitely is. Yeah.
我认为其他研究人员已经开始问这类问题，而且我自己也尝试过，我想，不是分类，而是某种，我想，甚至不是分类阴谋论，而是试图隔离其中一些特征，但这实际上非常困难，因为有这么多关于这么多不同事件的阴谋论，你指出了地平说阴谋论，它一直存在，但，嗯，消失了很长一段时间，然后在最近几年似乎又流行起来了，嗯，我确实发现很难解释这一点，我的意思是，我有一个关于那个阴谋论的理论，即人们目前普遍对科学和科学家变得不那么信任，这就是为什么我们可能会看到这类想法卷土重来。
I think that other researchers have started to ask these sorts of questions, but, and I have tried myself to, I guess, not taxonomized, but sort of almost, I guess, not even categorized conspiracy theories but try to isolate some of these features but it's actually very difficult because there are so many of them about so many different events and you pointed out the um flat earth conspiracy theory which has been around forever but um kind of died away for a long time and then in recent years just seems to have gotten popular again um and i do find it quite difficult to explain that i mean i I have a theory about that conspiracy theory that just generally people are becoming less trustful of science and scientists at the present time, which is why we might be seeing these sorts of ideas making a bit of a comeback.
但是的，不，我认为这是一个非常、非常引人入胜的问题。是的，因为并不是说它们中的一些消失了，它们就走了，而是它们又回来了。或者以不同的形式回来，或者特定的阴谋论。关于特定的事情，比如反疫苗或与健康相关的阴谋论，可以为发生的新事情重新发明自己，比如关于人们因手机信号塔生病的5G阴谋论等等，所以这类阴谋论一直存在，它们变异了，我想如果你喜欢的话，它们改变了，但是的，我认为这是一个非常引人入胜的问题，作为一个社会心理学家，我无法很好地回答，
But yeah, no, I think it's a really, really fascinating question. Yeah, because it's not that even some of them disappear, they go away, but then they come back again. Or come back again in a different form or certain conspiracy theory. about particular things like say anti-vaccine or health-related conspiracy theories can kind of reinvent themselves for new things that happen like 5G conspiracy theories about people getting sick from phone masks and things like that so these sorts of conspiracy theories have always been there they kind of mutate I suppose if you like they change but yeah I think it is a really fascinating question and one that I can't, as a social psychologist, can't really answer very well,
不幸的是。当一个阴谋论出现后，有什么办法可以有效地揭穿它吗？我的意思是，你可以只陈述事实吗？就像你谈到的反疫苗者，你知道，那篇导致很多关于儿童因疫苗而患自闭症的信仰的《柳叶刀》文章，后来证明那篇文章是伪造的。它是基于错误的数据，并且被撤回了，然而有些人仍然坚持这一点。那么有什么办法可以阻止这些理论继续流传吗？是的，有办法做到这一点。但当然，这极具挑战性。这非常、非常困难。一旦这些阴谋论出现并且人们相信它们，那么有时人们可以非常、非常强烈地坚持这些信仰，并且
unfortunately. Is there any way to effectively debunk a conspiracy theory once it's out there? I mean, can you just present the facts? Like you talked about the anti-vaxxers, you know, the fact that the Lancet article that kind of led to a lot of beliefs that children were becoming autistic as a result of vaccines and then it turned out that that article was was bogus. It was based on faulty data and it was retracted and yet some people are still hanging on to that. So is there a way to stop these theories from continuing to swirl? Yes, there are ways to do this. But of course, it's extremely challenging. It's very, very difficult. Once these conspiracy theories are out there and people believe them, then sometimes people can very, very strongly hold on to these beliefs and
也非常、非常强烈地捍卫它们。一旦这些态度非常、非常强烈，当然，从心理学的其他领域，我们知道非常强烈持有的态度很难反驳，我想，很难，很难改变。改变这类态度非常困难。所以是的，这是一个挑战，但确实有一些事情可以做，而且很多研究，特别是在非常、非常近的几年里，也开始出现，关于你如何，你如何处理错误信息？你如何处理阴谋论？在某些情况下，给人们事实确实有效。在我们自己的一些研究中，我们实际上发现，在人们接触阴谋论之前，向人们提供事实信息，向人们提供事实，是非常有效的，
defend them very, very strongly as well. And once these attitudes are very, very strong, of course, from other areas of psychology, we know that attitudes that are very strongly held are difficult to dispute, I guess, difficult to, difficult to change. It's very difficult to change these sorts of attitudes. And so yes, it is a challenge, but there are things that that can be done and a lot of research that especially in very, very recent years as well, has started to come out in terms of how do you, how do you address misinformation? How do you address conspiracy theories? And giving people the facts does work under certain situations. In some of our own research, we've actually found that it's quite effective to provide people with factual information, provide people with the facts,
这特别关于疫苗，然后阴谋论就无法获得牵引力。但一旦人们接触了阴谋论，那么之后给他们，我想，抱歉，适当或正确的信息并不能真正起作用。所以其他人已经采纳了这些信息，并开始寻找为人们接种疫苗以抵御错误信息的方法，并为人们接种疫苗以抵御阴谋论和假新闻以及所有其他各种事情，这似乎也有效。所以换句话说，你在他们接触到最糟糕的错误信息之前，给人们提供正确的信息或一些微弱的错误信息，那么这有助于他们能够抵御它。人们使用了其他技术，
and this was particularly about vaccines, before they're exposed to conspiracy theories, and then the conspiracy theory sort of fails to gain traction. But once the people have been exposed to the conspiracy theory, then giving them the, I guess, sorry, the appropriate or correct information afterwards doesn't really work. So others have sort of taken this information and have started to look at ways to inoculate people against misinformation and to inoculate people against conspiracy theories and fake news and all sorts of other things, which seems to be working as well. So in other words, you give people either the correct information or some piece of weak misinformation before they're exposed to the worst of. of it, then that helps them to be able to resist it. There are other techniques that people have used,
研究人员也使用过。仅举一个例子，一些研究人员研究了向人们提供预警或预告的想法，即他们可能会接触到错误信息。如果人们认为他们可能收到的信息可能是误导性的，并且他们预先掌握了该信息，
that researchers have used as well. And just to give you one other example, some researchers have looked at the idea of presenting people with a pre-warning or a forewarning that they might be exposed to misinformation. And if people believe that information that they might receive could be misleading, and they have that information up front,
那么这有时也可以帮助他们抵御错误信息。现在，我认为这些都是非常、非常宝贵的工具，但当然，有时错误信息已经存在了。所以很难提前接触到人们。所以你必须诉诸，我想，传统的揭穿技术，比如带着一致、强有力的反驳论点进入。但我认为这些其他机会，这些其他，嗯，提供了真正的机会来帮助人们抵御他们将来可能遇到的阴谋论。所以如果你给人们这些，我想，批判性思考信息的方式，并思考，嗯，你知道，好吧，我可能会接触到错误信息。那个错误信息就在那里。所以我将留意它。
then that can sometimes help them to resist the misinformation as well. Now, I think these are all really, really valuable tools, but of course, sometimes the misinformation is already out there. So it's difficult to get to people beforehand. So then you have to resort to, I guess, traditional debunking techniques such as going in with consistent, strong counter arguments. But I think that these other opportunities, these other, um, provides real opportunities to help people to resist conspiracy theories in general that they might come across in the future. So if you give people these sorts of, I guess, ways to critically think about information and think, well, you know, okay, I could be exposed to misinformation. That misinformation is out there. So I'm going to be on the lookout for it.
那么这实际上可能有助于人们在下次遇到它时抵御它，如果这说得通的话。是的。是的，听起来像是他们现在试图在新冠疫苗上使用的技术，提前告诉人们，你知道，如果你碰巧特别过敏，你可能会有反应，这就是预期的结果。然而，这有点像打地鼠游戏，因为他们谈论所有这些，并且他们试图尽可能透明。然而，有人走过来说，这其中涉及的mRNA实际上
Then it might actually help people to resist it when they come across it next time, if that makes sense. Yeah. Yeah, it sounds like the techniques that they're trying to use right now with the COVID-19 vaccines, telling people up front that, you know, if you happen to be particularly allergic, you might have a reaction, this is what to expect. And yet it's kind of like a game of whack-a-mole because they talk about all of this and they're trying to be as transparent as possible. And yet along comes somebody who says that the MRNA that's involved in this is actually
会改变你体内的DNA。所以，你知道，你怎么反击那个？是的，这非常、非常，这确实非常、非常困难。而且一直有新的阴谋论。它完全就像那个游戏。你一直在试图，你有一个，然后你一直在试图打掉另一个。这非常、非常具有挑战性。
going to change the DNA in your body. And so, you know, how do you fight that? Yeah, it's very, very, it is very, very difficult. and there are new conspiracy theories all the time. It is exactly like that game. You're constantly trying to, you've got one, and then you're constantly trying to hit another one away. It is very, very challenging.
外面有很多，很多东西。当然，这一切都因为有时阴谋确实存在，有时人们可能有根深蒂固、合理的理由不信任权威而变得复杂。例如，民意调查发现，黑人美国人不太可能说他们会接种新冠疫苗，并且更担心其安全性，因为他们有被医疗机构虐待和不公正对待的悠久历史。那么人们有什么办法可以平衡这种意识与对阴谋论的健康怀疑吗？是的。同样，这极具挑战性，你是绝对正确的，有些人有
There's a lot, there's a lot out there, what going on out there. And of course, this is all complicated by the fact that sometimes conspiracies do exist, and sometimes people may have deep-seated, valid reasons to distrust authority. So, for example, public opinion polls have found that black, Americans are less likely to say they'll take the COVID vaccine and more wary of its safety because they have a long history of being abused and mistreated by the medical establishment. So is there a way for people to balance this awareness with a healthy skepticism of conspiracy theories? Yes. Again, this is extremely challenging and you're absolutely right that some people have
非常好的理由怀疑这类事情，因为过去的事件。所以挑战变得更大了。我不知道这个问题的解决方案，除了试图打击错误信息的人需要对这些担忧保持敏感，并可能在他们揭穿错误信息的努力中更有针对性，同时对这些历史事件保持敏感。所以这不一定是对错误信息的一刀切的方法，只是不能，因为
very good reasons to be suspicious of these sorts of things because of past events. and so the challenge becomes even greater. And I don't know the solution to this, apart from the fact that people who are attempting to fight the misinformation will need to be sensitive to these concerns and perhaps be more targeted in their efforts to debunk the misinformation being sensitive to these historical events as well. So it can't necessarily be a one-size-fits-all approach to misinformation just can't be because
鉴于过去发生的事件，对这类事情保持怀疑是非常有充分理由的。因此，挑战变得更加艰巨。我不知道解决这个问题的办法，除了那些试图打击虚假信息的人需要对这些担忧保持敏感，并且在揭穿虚假信息时或许需要更有针对性，同时也要考虑到这些历史事件。所以，针对虚假信息的方法不一定能一刀切，根本就不可能。
everybody's circumstances are different. And we know that different communities feel differently about vaccines and various other things as well for very good reasons. So that, of course, is a huge challenge for anybody trying to deal with potential misinformation about vaccines and other things, but also, yeah, particularly with COVID, a reluctance. to take the vaccine. So what aspects of conspiracy theory are you looking at today? What's your research heading toward?
每个人的情况都不同。我们也知道，不同的群体出于非常正当的理由，对疫苗以及其他各种事物的看法也各不相同。因此，对于任何试图处理有关疫苗和其他事物的潜在错误信息的人来说，这当然是一个巨大的挑战，尤其是对于新冠疫苗，人们对接种疫苗存在抵触情绪。那么，您今天关注的是阴谋论的哪些方面？您的研究方向是什么？
Quite a few things going on at the moment, actually. I'm really interested in, I guess, the deliberate use of conspiracy theories as a political device. So I've been doing some research, I guess, looking at how people perceive others who are seen to use conspiracy theories and whether or not they see those actions as intentional or deliberate and also what the effects are of of that. I've also been interested in the term conspiracy theory itself and the term conspiracy theorist and how people use those terms whether they use them to I guess
目前确实有很多事情在进行。我非常感兴趣的是，我认为阴谋论被蓄意用作一种政治手段。所以我一直在做一些研究，观察人们如何看待那些被认为使用阴谋论的人，以及他们是否认为这些行为是有意或蓄意的，以及这些行为会产生什么影响。我也一直对“阴谋论”这个词本身以及“阴谋论者”这个词感兴趣，以及人们如何使用这些词，他们是否使用这些词来，我想
specifically put down other people's ideas or if they simply use these terms when people, when they just don't believe, they don't believe a particular idea and also the effects of these terms on whether or not someone will actually believe something. What else have I been doing? Oh, quite a few things going on.
专门贬低他人的观点，或者他们只是在不相信某种特定观点时使用这些词，以及这些词对某人是否真的会相信某事有什么影响。我还做了些什么？哦，有很多事情在进行。
I've been writing quite a bit about COVID-19 conspiracy theories and also quite generally my research is focused a lot on the consequences of believing in conspiracy theories as well. So in different areas like in vaccines, climate change, politics, in various different domains, specifically what impact do conspiracy theories have on people's attitudes, beliefs and behaviors. So I've been doing a lot on that sort of thing. Well, it's an amazing area for scrutiny and and appreciate the work that you're doing here in helping us to better understand some of the ways
我写了很多关于新冠肺炎阴谋论的文章，而且总的来说，我的研究很大程度上也集中在相信阴谋论的后果上。因此，在不同的领域，如疫苗、气候变化、政治等各个领域，阴谋论具体对人们的态度、信念和行为有什么影响。所以我一直在做很多这方面的工作。嗯，这是一个非常值得审视的领域，感谢您在这里所做的工作，帮助我们更好地理解人们思维方式的一些途径
that people's minds work. So thank you so much for joining us today, Dr. Douglas. Well, thank you. It's been a pleasure. If you'd like to learn more about psychological research on conspiracy theories and other types of misinformation, check out The Monitor on Psychology, the magazine of the American Psychological Association. You can find it at www.apa.org slash monitor.
所以非常感谢您今天加入我们，道格拉斯博士。嗯，谢谢。这是我的荣幸。如果您想了解更多关于阴谋论和其他类型错误信息的心理学研究，请查看美国心理学会的杂志《心理学监测》。您可以在 www.apa.org/monitor 上找到它。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeatingof psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Rob and Eva. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 SpeakingofPsychology，连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是罗伯·恩瓦。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目。
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。